explosions thunder and smoke rises from
the azostal steel plant one of the
biggest metallurgical plants in europe a
warren of buildings and tunnels where
ukrainian forces are holed up as russia
tries to take full control of mariupol
russia's defense ministry says according
to ukrainians who surrendered there are
up to 400 foreign fighters inside
including canadians that has not been
verified but analysts say it's plausible
we've seen pretty clear evidence that
canadians in pretty in sizable numbers
have taken steps to
join the fight in ukraine
the ukrainian government has gone out of
its way to make that easier canada has
advised against all travel to ukraine
russia has labeled those foreign
fighters mercenaries meaning they would
not be entitled to the protections of
the geneva convention if captured it is
scary because the mercenary line would
give russia
some
ability to do things to those people
those presumed canadians
that they wouldn't be able to do to
normal pows walter dorn disputes
russia's position saying canadians
fighting are under the command and
control of ukraine and says if there are
canadians captured in as of stall they
may become bargaining chips in some kind
of prisoner swap similar to these two
british pows obviously i'd really
appreciate your help in this matter they
appeared on russian state tv monday
captured in mario poll asking boris
johnson to exchange them for an ally of
putin with a similar plea it's not clear
whether any of the men were speaking
freely it's also unclear how many
civilians may be inside the steel plant
this video shared on a twitter account
called canadian ukrainian volunteer
claims that alice is inside the plant
her mom an army medic tending the
wounded neither global affairs canada
nor the foreign affairs minister's
office would confirm whether any
canadians are in is off stall saying
they don't have a record of canadians
who choose to travel but the department
did tell global news they haven't had
any calls for help from any canadians
inside the plant noting they may not be
able to help canadians who are injured
or captured by russian forces abigail
beeman global news ottawa